Hello Diablo community, welcome to another Diablo 4 Campfire Chat.
This is our PTR Campfire Chat for Season 8.
My name is Adam Fletcher, I'm the Director of Community here.
Of course I'm joined by this panel.
A lot of familiar faces, do you guys want to introduce yourself?
Hi, I'm Colin Feiner, I'm a Design Director on Diablo 4.
Hey, I'm Derek Nunez, I'm a Lead Seasons Designer here on Diablo 4.
And hi, I'm Charles Dunn, I'm a Class Designer working on the Final Design team.
Awesome, and we're also joined by Ruben, Ruben Marquez, aka Bloodshed.
He's actually behind the scenes, he'll be playing through some gameplay that we're going to be showing off here.
Hello.
Oh, there he is, he's saying hi, waving.
We'll see more of him here in a little bit with, maybe not Marak, Stan anymore.
We got to see a good minute and a half of him before the stream actually started.
Crazy day.
First, I do want to start off with that we had a smoothie delivery this morning, and Marcus is not here.
As you can see, I'm here hosting this because he forgot my smoothie in the order.
So I just kicked him off the stream.
No, I'm just kidding.
But I told him I'd bring it up because I'm like, oh, my smoothie's not here.
But either way, we have a lot to talk about regarding Season 8.
And that's actually the end of the stream, so that's all I wanted to bring up.
Thank you.
No, we have a lot to talk about for Season 8 PTR, but I know a few other topics that we wanted to hit on
was kind of related to some of the quality of life stuff that's going to be coming with this specific season
based off of feedback and things we've seen within the game.
And also one big topic is around mid-season updates.
It's actually something that a lot of people have been asking about.
And we do want to give a little bit of an update on what mid-season updates will be going forward
and how we're kind of thinking about it from here.
So, Colin, did you want to talk a little bit about how we're planning on doing mid-season updates?
Yeah, I think first it's helpful to sort of talk about the history of the mid-season balance patch.
Originally, when we had talked about mid-season, it was pretty early in the lifecycle of Diablo 4.
We would add a ton of items and we do sort of envision doing a lot of big swings
in terms of big nerfs to overperforming builds and big buffs to underperforming builds.
But as we've seen, as we've added more progression and things like Season 4 itemization,
there's a lot more time investment in terms of getting your build online and really refining and optimizing it.
And what we found is when you put so much time into your character, it feels really bad when we nerf things, right?
So, Season 6 is a great example where you might have done so much work to temper your gear
and masterwork your gear and level up those paragons that we were really hesitant to do
like a big nerf swing as part of the mid-season balance patch.
Sort of on the other hand, right, we didn't want to massively buff underperforming builds
to match the overperforming builds because we didn't want to create this insane, you know,
sort of arms race and then we're at pit tier 9000, right?
It'd be ridiculous.
So what we ended up doing was actually kind of like anemic number of tweaks.
Like they weren't really necessarily making a big impact.
And we took a step back and sort of asked ourselves like, well, what are we actually getting out of this?
What are you, the players, actually getting out of this?
And I think we're at a sort of point where we want to pivot and adjust our philosophy a little bit.
And I think we've already seen some of this philosophy come to life in Season 7.
Yeah, exactly.
I know, especially in the beginning of the season, people probably saw us make some tweaks
in the first couple of weeks related to some really crazy numbers that maybe they weren't even numbers
in some of the stuff that people saw in the start of the actual season.
Yeah.
So all that is to say, I think really what we're going to start taking a look at is not doing massive swings in the midseason,
but instead focusing our efforts on the launch of a season.
So we're going to take that time and we're going to make sure that like there's a much higher quality launch release
and taking a lot of that balance time and making sure that when we do launch a season, it's higher quality, right?
We want the pit tier disparities to be a little bit lower.
We want to make sure that, you know, when a new season launches, the new builds that we're adding are going to be really effective
and there's a lot of new fun ways to play.
This doesn't mean we're never going to balance or touch the game.
It actually means we're just going to shift our efforts to the beginning of the season.
So early on, we're going to be pretty vigilant in terms of things that are underperforming or way overperforming
and acting quickly on them.
Yeah.
The goal here is really to get everything closer in terms of like just like less egregious, you know, builds being super, super high up there.
We saw that, I think, specifically in like season six with like the spirit born and it kind of stayed consistent that way.
We know we got a lot of feedback of like, hey, this feels kind of poopy if, you know, my build is like, you know, 30, 40 pit tiers below.
And so the goal is really to kind of bring and keep things more aligned, especially at the start of the season.
So as Colin mentioned, in the first couple of weeks, I know there's going to be more effort in putting tweaks during that time to really respect the player's time as well.
Yeah.
Oh, go ahead.
The timing is really important because like our mid-season updates in the past had come a month or a month and a half into the season once players have been really invested in their build.
And now we're going to be much more focused on rapid updates, you know, within a week or two after the season launch to make sure that if we are making those adjustments, it's at a point where, hey, you're not, you know, you're not complete with the season.
You're not done yet.
And you can adjust and you can, you know, make sure that your time is respected in that way.
Definitely.
So to really clarify, you know, when the season launches, I'll use Bloodwave as an example.
That was something we saw pretty early on and it was way too overtuned, right?
Like you didn't even really have to invest in your character to get to a point where you're godlike.
And that is something that we would probably act quickly on as a part of the next season, for example.
And I think like a big point of clarity is like Bloodwave using that as an example is very much an S tier build right now in this season.
S plus.
Yeah, S plus for sure.
I think that the goal is not to immediately take it to F or even immediately take it to C or anything like that.
It's really keep it still an S but like also make sure that it's still like at least lined up with like the other builds that might be up there in that top tier.
Yeah.
Conversely too, I just want to make it super clear.
If we see things that we added that are new, for example, if the seasonal powers aren't performing in a way that feels really powerful and crunchy, we're going to be buffing those.
So it's not only looking out for the S plus, it's also looking for the things that missed the mark.
So we're going to be buffing those also.
Awesome.
Yeah.
So I know that players at the start of season eight will see us be a lot more reactionary towards those first couple weeks in the early part of that season.
So yeah, just wanted to clarify that with players because we've seen a lot of questions about mid-season updates.
Is this a mid-season update when they see a patch or something like that?
And so going forward, I know that's going to be the plan as we look at updating the game in the future.
And if you hide things early, I will Liam Nees in your ass.
I will know.
There you go.
We heard it first.
Colin's just waiting behind you.
That's what he does.
In the closet.
Yeah.
Like the little demon kid right behind you.
Exactly.
The other thing that we want to talk about is kind of like state of the game, especially with season seven, where we're at and kind of how we're looking at that towards season eight.
I think one of the biggest points of feedback we've heard related to season seven is kind of the pace of the game.
Yeah.
You know, sometimes you blink and you're level 20 and you're like, holy crap, what happened?
So I know you wanted to talk a little bit more about that as well.
Yeah, absolutely.
So just sort of our perspective on season seven has been the progression is very fast, way faster than we sort of expected.
Part of it is a lot of the really cool new seasonal powers.
Part of it's the head hunts being super lucrative and awesome.
And part of it's also just like the seasonal journey and the reputation board.
There's a lot of different ways to get a ton of power in Diablo 4.
And what we've seen is compared to season six, which had a lot of positive feedback as part of our rebound progression model,
is that a lot of that has sort of gone down the drain in terms of how fast players are chewing through some of the content.
So we actually have a graph that we could look at.
I apologize.
This is terrible.
But I just pulled it from the stat, our sort of stat page.
It's not the greatest.
But this is a picture of season six.
You can see on the Y-axis here.
It was taking roughly people around 15 to 17 hours on average to get to max level.
We felt like that was a pretty good journey, right?
Part of Diablo is that sort of zero to hero journey.
And part of what's fun about leveling is you start to sort of form a build and find a lot of different pieces early on
when you're still forming your character where customization is really fun, right?
You're not necessarily locked into a build.
So we felt like that was a pretty good clip for hitting max level.
It's on average, right?
So you could either go faster or slower depending on sort of how much of a blaster you are.
So we felt like that was a pretty good average, especially with difficulty tiers and your ability to sort of go faster or slower based on your pacing.
And let's go to season seven now.
And it nearly doubled.
So you can see that it was taking about nine hours on average, which is kind of insane, right?
Again, this is the average.
So if you're, you know, if you're like a Wodijo of the world, it's probably more like two hours or like 30 minutes.
And that was something that we definitely feel like has sort of missed the mark in terms of that initial journey.
So we are going to be making some changes just to adjust for a lot of the seasonal power and things like that.
We're not going to necessarily nerf the power of the seasonal power.
We still want you to feel powerful.
But we are going to essentially take a look at the one to 25 experience and just smooth that out a little bit,
which is going to essentially make the leveling experience a little bit closer to season six.
So it is going to be a slower from one to 25.
But one thing we've done to sort of compensate that is we've taken a look at the itemization.
We don't like that rares and sort of magic items immediately disappear after the first five minutes of the game.
Yeah, I think you kind of get to that point.
Like we were talking about if you get to like level 20, you blink and you're level 20.
And then at the same time you blink and you're like, oh, blues and yellows.
Like, I only look at oranges now.
Or like, what's this other color?
So I know that we have some changes that you wanted to talk about.
Yeah, and again, like a lot of this is in the spirit of making sure that zero to hero journey is really satisfying, right?
That's what makes it so awesome when playing Diablo is that sort of I start with nothing and become a god, right?
So we are taking a look at the itemization so that it doesn't just feel like a slog from one to 25.
What we're going to be doing is, oh, you know what?
I'm going to jump actually into the legendaries really quick because it's really important, a really important part of this.
The other thing that was contributing to this leveling sort of pace was that players are getting a legendary every three to four minutes.
And that's from one to 60.
That's not just in the end game.
And it just felt like legendary item quality was just too prevalent across the leveling journey.
You didn't have, you sort of hit max level.
There was no journey to assembling your build.
You just had everything as part of the codex of power.
So we're also reducing the legendary rate from leveling.
We're not really touching the end game legendary drop rates, but from leveling we are adjusting that.
And to compensate that, to jump back into the magic and rares.
We're making it so that magics can have up to two affixes.
So sometimes you're going to find, you know, from your one to 25 journey a pretty good magic item.
It might actually be better than a rare, for example, because it might have dropped earlier for you.
It might have higher eye power.
And then we're also making it so that rares can sometimes have up to three affixes.
And what that means is, you know, when you get a drop at level 35 from a whisper cache, right now, you know, in Season 7 it feels terrible when you don't get a legendary item.
Because you just know that it's just not even worth looking at, right?
But now that rare items can have up to three affixes, that means that you might have a really good imprintable base.
It means all the rares that drop across the game from 1 to 60 could actually be pretty great gear for you.
Especially with all of our crafting options.
So we think that this helps smooth out the 1 to 60 journey.
I will caveat that the rare quality is not the best at max level still.
It's going to be a lower eye power, so you're not going to have to filter through a bunch of rares at max level.
We're not going to go back to pre-season 4.
So, yeah, we think this is this sort of smoothing out of the leveling curve, taking a look at the magic rarities or the item qualities,
is just going to make the experience feel a lot more rewarding and satisfying as you go through these levels.
And then I know some of the other items we've been talking about have been a little bit of that torment progression.
We've seen drastic differences between Season 6 to Season 7, and it's something I know we're making tweaks to.
Yeah, so the other half of Diablo is obviously the max level endgame, right?
And we've heard a ton of feedback that it just feels like a weak endgame right now.
You can just blast through all the torment tiers.
There's nothing that's really satisfying about it.
There's nothing to work towards just because you're just getting so much power so frequently and just really crushing this content.
So what we've done here is, if we go to the slide, we've actually given...
Actually, let me jump into some of the stats here because I think it's really interesting.
A lot of people got to Torment 4 very quickly.
So on average, it was taking players around 15 hours to get to Torment 4.
That's roughly double how quickly it took in Season 6, which is kind of insane.
Again, it's the culmination of Seasonal Powers and all this crazy stuff going on.
And the other part of it is that 50% of players are actually hitting Torment 4.
And just from a philosophy standpoint, we really want whatever the hardest Torment tier is, in this case Torment 4, to be aspirational.
And to us, that means around 10%.
That means that, you know, if you're really Johnny Badass, you know, you need to be in the top 10% of players to actually get there.
And it's not hitting the mark.
So what we're going to do is make some adjustments.
So Torment 1 is now going to start at Pit Tier 10, which means we've effectively added 10 Pit Tiers to the Pit because now Torment 1 starts earlier.
And then we've also increased the Torment Pit Scaling health by roughly 20% multiplicative and then some damage increases.
Yeah, and that Pit Scaling is, every level of a Pit is multiplicative on previous levels.
So it's not just like, oh, whatever Pit I was at, it's now 20% harder.
It's actually like kind of stacking 20% every level.
So the end result is that, you know, a Pit Tier 100 is much harder than it was before.
And that will, that makes it, you know, harder to reach that absolute highest end.
And it gives you a little bit more for those builds and those Blasters who are getting up to that highest Pit Tier.
There's going to be, it's going to be quite a bit harder to get to quite that same level next season.
Yeah, absolutely.
So with that, sort of culminates in moving Torment 1 to Pit Tier 10 and effectively adding 10 Pit Tiers
and increasing the multiplicative scaling of the Pit Tier scaling is the journey is going to be a lot more sort of satisfying.
There's a lot more sort of peaks to climb.
And it also means Pit Tier 150 is going to be very difficult.
So, so difficult that I don't believe any of you will reach it.
I don't know, I'll do something silly on the stream.
He says this now.
I'll probably, oh, that's not enough for doing something silly on the stream.
And then like within the first stream.
That's a challenge to all of you out there.
Yeah, you all can vote on the silly thing that I do.
But conversely, I just want to cover this really quickly though.
Torment 4 isn't going to be insanely harder than it was before.
It's going to be roughly around Pit Tier 76 is on live right now.
So season 7.
So think about the game that you're playing right now.
Torment 4 is going to be about 11 Pit Tiers harder.
So it's still achievable.
It's just that upper end is also just going to be that much harder to sort of climb through.
Awesome.
So we've got a lot of changes coming for like Torment Scaling.
Obviously some itemization changes.
So the big thing being as you're leveling up, you're going to see a lot more opportunities to find items.
Especially with the changes to blue and yellow items there.
And then of course, as you mentioned, the big caveat is like at 60, the item power on Legendaries is still going to be the best method and the best items to actually grab.
So yeah, lots of big changes coming up.
Great to actually walk through all of them.
I know we have a ton more to talk about specifically around the new season.
So thank you, Colin.
We're going to jump over to Derek because I know we do want to talk about the new season and what players are actually going to be experiencing in this PTR.
Again, just to redefine what PTR is for some people because I got messages from people going like, well, PTRs are sometimes buggy.
And I'm like, well, it's a PTR.
So it is like a beta or an alpha, an early look into a game.
So we expect that.
There will be like known issues and we'll actually have those known issues on our forums.
So people can actually see them.
You can report bugs.
It actually helps when you guys actually jump into a PTR and experience it and give us feedback because that helps tweak the start of the season for the better, essentially.
But with season eight, we will be having, of course, a PTR and we'll be talking about it here in a second.
And really amplify or celebrate or enhance it within that respective season.
So we've seen that with Season Four with the Helltide revamps and whatnot, as you mentioned.
Season seven was the emphasis on the Tree of Whispers and Bounties.
so as colin kind of mapped out the journey to the end game we wanted to shine focus on a major end
game uh feature namely surrounding our bosses and we have a lot of really cool bosses in you know
the world of sanctuary but more specifically the lair boss system or as some of us and we reference
it to as the boss ladder um so season eight focus is on the lair boss system we're going to be doing
a whole mess of new things to it so we're adding new bosses uh new mechanics quality of life
updates and a revamped materials loop that i'm going to be covering throughout the course of
the segment um so you know first i just want to kind of talk about you know the new bosses and
additions to the roster so when we're talking about the lair bosses these are like the biggest baddest
you know bosses of sanctuary um so we're looking at how do we add to the roster in a meaningful way
but also which bosses do we add that are impactful and versatile enough to carry the entire theme of
a season so with that in mind we're just asking ourselves a question of which of the right bosses
to bring you mentioned an old friend so we had to choose something that was versatile we had to
choose something that was big bad so that's where we go to belial yes season eight belial's return
belial's back in sanctuary he is climbing his way to the top of the lair boss ladder he is the new
you know exalted pinnacle challenge within the ladder he is the highest challenge the highest
reward and he also has some very uh unique reward related uh tricks up his sleeve that i'll cover a
little bit later so for now just know that belial's back and he's also just not joining the party alone
he's bringing a couple of friends from our vessel of hatred so first up is our buddy urvar so urvar is
joining the roster of the lair boss uh ladder system uh he's going to be filling out kind of like the
lowest rung of the ladder so he's going to be joining the party with the varshans and the
beast of nice and whatnot um so urvar is back and we're also bringing back another vessel of hatred
uh character the harbinger of hatred i'm so happy for this yeah no this one i love this fight we're
going to see a little bit more of this guy in just a little bit but uh the harbinger of hatred
will be joining kind of the second rung of the ladder uh with the likes of duriel and andariel
and one thing i just do want to stress is that both these vessel of hatred bosses will dip into
the shared loot pools of other bosses within their respective tier but also have some uh additional
bonuses that is specific to the vessel of hatred like being a great source of tributes and runes
but belial for all intents and purposes is available to everyone and he is just the new pinnacle
challenge of the boss ladder so you're saying even harder than duriel and andariel right now
he's going to be harder more rewarding than even those absolutely yes yeah you're top tier
yeah new top tier blot lord of lies he does not mess around and i'm really excited about this because
i think this is going to pair really well with the sort of leveling journey in the torment progression
where we're making things a little bit more aspirational a little bit more challenging it's
really like a return to the heart of the diablo experience right sort of leveling from nothing
and taking on these huge big bads to claim their loot yeah absolutely i think that's kind of the
inherent cool thing about the lair boss ladder system is that you start with like the initiate
level floor you take those on you graduate to the next level and then now you have kind of belial just
always there looming over you that's kind of the aspirational yes i get to go fight him now
um but for those who know about our buddy belial lord of lies you know that he kind of appears in
different forms so this is what we're kind of referencing is like his supreme form that appears at the
top of the lair boss ladder but he also has his uh i guess smaller more agile compact form i like
to effectually refer to him as baby belial but this is belial in his more compact form and throughout the
course of the season or i guess just the lair boss mechanics he's going to be popping up all over the
place but i'm really excited about this version of belial's new role in the lair boss ladder system in the
sense that defeating and looting any of the lair bosses has a small percent chance to initiate a
surprise ambush from belial himself and this is really cool because this is kind of like a two for
the price of one payout so let's say i fight and dario i defeat and dario i loot and dario and i get
this special ambush triggered and if i defeat belial i'll get a double payout of and dario's loot so i
got the loot from and dario and i get another payout of and dario's loot from defeating belial himself
so it's it's really exciting kind of just like injection of some you know fun novel mechanics
within the lair boss system that we're doing over and over and over again um so again really excited
about this update and again in the spirit of teasing kind of the rewards relationship and
connection that belial has this version of belial has a very special connection to his larger supreme
form in in the lair boss ladder that i'll touch upon a little bit later a lot of teasing that i'm
kind of just sending that there's a lot to go over we're gonna lie to everybody yeah we're just kidding
yeah the theme yeah belial's actually not here this is a lie yeah um yeah so so that was that that
you know the blau ambushes but i also want to talk about um some additional major sweeping updates
that's coming in with just the system as a whole and i want to talk about the summoning materials
um as we know the way that the system currently functions is you know you go do activities you get
summoning items you go visit the boss and you plop them in you summon the boss and then you know
that's kind of just a flow so when we're looking at the lair boss system we don't just look about
ways that we can add to it we also look about um you know opportunities to you know resolve or reduce
some frictions or just areas for improvement that we can have with it since it's a very mature system
we get a lot of feedback that we you know you know diligently ingest and talk about and whatnot on our
team so when it came to the summoning materials we identified a couple of key points of i guess
friction that players are currently having with it one is since you have to ante up your summoning
materials just to summon the boss it's kind of a feels bad moment when you realize that you just
wasted you know x number of materials to find out that you can't defeat durial like okay that's
wasting materials back to the loop maybe i'll fight him another week or two depending how fast you are
and it's just generally not a great feeling for for myself or for players and whatnot yeah i definitely
have run into this where it's like i'm only going to fight the boss when i can guaranteed win
against it right right so you never actually and how do you know that too until like you know
travel and error like you never really have that like actual fun fight with the boss where you're
like oh am i going to lose or not because it's like well i'm just not going to risk it yeah i've
had at times where i'm like i don't know if my build's quite ready so i'll try to fight a boss
and then i'm like oh this is really tough like i die a couple times i'm like do i really want to keep
like retrying it yeah because like well i've already invested i'm kind of like i'm kind of committed
uh so with this new way you know i don't i don't need to invest those right up front i can just go and
and fight them right away and see how how strong i am uh without risking the materials yeah yeah so
we're going to cover like the specificities of the new system and how it all works a little bit
but the other kind of pain point that we identified with the current system is also just in regards
to like the party play i think my little earpiece is coming out of my ear there you go it's a common
theme on this one yeah the earpiece just pops out all the time um we do it live here um yeah so the
other element is like just a party play right and as much as we want to kind of like entrust in our
fellow man and whatnot and engage in the boss rotations and whatnot we have seen you know some
areas of friction where certain players don't engage in the boss rotations and they don't submit
their materials like no one watching the stream would ever be guilty of this but that does happen
it's shocking but it does happen belial is on the other side of the computer yeah i'll definitely pay
the next rotation yeah and then they leave and they take all their stuff so that was another kind of
area of friction um that we experienced with the current summoning materials so i think that's kind
of enough of a preface just to set the tone for where the system is going now that we're introducing
season eight so so what are we doing what do we i don't know let's find out all right so layer keys
so summoning materials are effectively being repurposed in their roles as a new item called layer keys
and what layer keys do well i'll just start with this is since there's no more summoning materials
that just means that effectively all layer bosses are free to summon yeah so if you're not sure if
you're ready to take on a varshan or a durial just go visit them you know kind of use them as a bit of
a training dummy to see if you can actually uh you know take them on but what layer keys now do is
they grant access to the defeated bosses horde or their treasure chest that they drop so now i'll just walk
you through kind of the new flow imagine this with me so you enter durial's lair you walk up to his
altar and you just click the altar to summon him again no cost to you you fight durial you defeat him
out pops his horde and now the shards of agony which is now the lair key you use that to open his
horde and get all the oodles of loot that you went to go visit him to do yeah and these work like hell
tight chests so you have to pay in order to get the loot and the only loot or the loot comes for the
person who pays yeah that's a very important distinction is that now every member in the
party needs to have the appropriate type and quantity of the lair keys to access the loot in
the horde and you can still trade your keys with your friends and things like that if you have
nine nine nine nine you know durial mats you can split them in half and give them to your buddies to
open the chest yeah absolutely sharing is caring in the system here and then of course if you're really
lucky you'll get a belial ambush and you can get double loot yeah yeah there you go uh so a lot again a lot
a lot of new avenues and ways to kind of uh you know experience the system um so we also have the
stygian stones um so stygian stones in season eight is living a new life now in the sense that we wanted
to ensure that every boss in the first rung of the ladder our initiate lair bosses the varshans griggers
beasts of nice lord's ears and ur of ours now that they're all equally relevant to getting you to
climb to the next rung so in addition to it kind of you can take a screenshot of this chart here i
won't try and walk through the entire thing but now stygian stones is a drop that can drop from any
of the initiate lair boss tier here and you can crush them into your lair key of choice for the second
rung of the lair bosses so let's say i fight grigor i get a stygian stone and i want to go fight
and dario i can just crush that into some and dario keys and again just giving a little bit more
flexibility and how players actually engage and progress through the lair boss ladder again as we
know all roads lead to belial lord of lies you know the top of the pinnacle of the ladder at the end
there's a lot all right final thing here is the item bloat reduction so again with this new system
we're consolidating all the lair keys to one lair key type per boss so no more kind of managing two
different materials and so i have enough material i have two of these five of these it's just one
material per boss we're increasing the item stacking of these to 99 again to cut down on some of that
bloat and one of my personal favorites here is that we're also normalizing the counts of required
lair keys per you know boss rank so all the initiate uh tiered bosses they require the same quantity of
their respective keys so to the graders and whatnot so again it's just cutting down on the total mental
math and memory uh that is kind of affecting the i guess like on ramping enjoyment of the current
system yeah and dario only needs one material for example as part of this yeah yeah absolutely so you
can see in this chart here you have pincushion dolls shard of agony or the stijian stone is kind
of the wild card that you can crush to any one of them so um let's say if andaro needed four pincushion
dolls you have three of them but you have one stijian stone you can crush that into a pincushion
doll and go get andaro's horde um so all right that was a a pretty big overview and a lot of talking
and charts but i want to take the time to you know throw it over uh to ruben and uh behind the scenes
here and kind of just get into just what this all looks like as part of this in-game flow
hello derek how you doing man i'm doing great how are you awesome yeah let me open up the menu for
you all right cool so in this walkthrough i'm just going to show you kind of uh we're going to show
you rather the new flow to access the lair bosses with a little bit of a sneak peek of the harbinger
of hatred so one thing i want to just call out real quick is kind of some of the quality of life
updates that we've taken to just the map presentation and the boss dungeon tool tips themselves and i'll kind
just go through these kind of itemized order so first all of the boss uh dungeon map icons have
been uh given a little bit of a a beautiful beautification treatment so they're a little
bit more bold red and easier to identify against the sea of other icons on the map but now i want to
talk about the tool tip and i'll just start from the you know top and go make my way down so the first
quality of life update that we added was just simply printing the name of the boss that lives that
resides within the dungeon um you know one of the kind of ambiguities that we have the previous uh
you know version of this uh system was not knowing specifically which boss lives in which dungeon like
oh who does live in the gaping crevice or who lives in the malignant uh tunnels um so now you can see
here that the harbinger of hatred lives in the harbinger's den this is probably not the best example
because who else would live in the harbinger's den uh yeah but he technically does live in every
single one of them yeah you don't know where he's at uh but yeah so you can see here now you know we
print the name of the uh lair boss that lives in the dungeon for a little bit easier find uh instead
of the main body description we also just give a little bit more guidance and information on uh you
know what the value of defeating this boss is and they're directing players to the fact that they are
a source of ancestral and mythic unique items um the last two updates here are some of my favorites of
this is that we also display now the required items uh that you need to access the lair boss's
hoard if you recall the previous um you know iteration that was not apparent to you so you
would kind of like waste the time traveling to the boss just to find out that oh i have three or four
abhorrence heart so i can't fight the boss yet so we wanted to again just smoothen out the access and
onboarding to the feature and i think my absolute favorite update of all this is you see at the bottom
we now have the ability to travel directly into the dungeon directly from the map so again no more
teleporting to the nearest waypoint uh we just pop directly in and just get into it and uh you know
we have a ruben loading into here and i think this is a great time to just outline i've talked about
the new bosses i've talked about new mechanics but we have a you know a collection of really great
existing lair bosses and one thing that we wanted to take is is an opportunity within the season was to
also enhance every other lair boss that exists within the system so every lair boss is getting a bit of a
difficulty spike and new mechanics you know to again freshen up the fights that we've been you know
knowing and love so if you fought you know the varshans or the durials or even the liliths you know over and
over and over again all this is in the ptr so definitely worth checking them out again to see
what's changed and you know how much uh different their experience is yeah durial has some messed up
surprises yeah durial eats you
but again so this is the harbinger of hatred and you know just as a reminder one thing that we do when
we add a boss to the to the lair boss system is we don't just take the carbon copy you know campaign
version of it we also take the opportunity to inject some really crazy mechanics so i don't necessarily
want to you know kind of spoil the surprises of the harbinger of hatred's mechanics here but he does get
pretty wild this is it this is a spectacle and a half of a fight and i'm really excited to have
players check it out so um yeah and i think uh i think this is about uh all we might want to show
of this guy yeah we probably won't go into it we don't want to spoil all the mechanics and everything
i even though we're kind of also spoiling a little bit of like a rogue build
you might have noticed some interesting things on rogue which i'll get to in a bit
it's it's spoil or it's teasing to make it teasing teasing teasing everyone along here
um but yeah so now that was a sneak peek at the harbinger of hatred we just talked about again
in case you missed it the all their bosses are getting a boost in both their performance and just
the mechanics that they have yep um but let's you know we fast forwarded past you know the harbinger
of hatred's fight so let's imagine a world that you know we fought through the whole thing we killed
him and let's show off now what to expect from the horde uh loop flow so we have some uh some footage
here with this very shiny very shiny chest um so we have four important hearts and now we can open
up the chest again each one of us needs to have it and i mentioned that belial has a chance to surprise
ambush you after opening any horde and here you go look at this this is meant to be a relatively rare
occurrence um but you know this is the the magic of pre-recorded footage we can make the impossible
happen and in this case again painting the full picture of the scenario you defeated the harbinger of
hatred you got the horde you opened it you got baby belial you killed him and now you get another
proc of yeah double the loot double the fun yeah double the loot of what you just essentially got
with the one time uh payment of the lair keys that you deposited so yeah it really is you know kind of
a two-for-one sale that belial has for you and if you noticed you might have seen we did keep a bonus
for party play so while you do have to pay to get the chest and open up the horde we kept a bonus chance
for loot so we love that people enjoy fighting the bosses as uh parties and we know that that's a fun
social experience in diablo so what we've done is the hordes themselves will have bonus chances for
loot when you are in a party and that does scale with party members yep no absolutely so yeah a lot
of loot everywhere to give and on the topic at the very top i teased that belial had a very special kind
of role in the reward structure different from every other boss so defeating the ambush version of belial
is not just lucrative in the sense that it's a double payout he is also the sole source of the lair keys
that you need to access his supreme form at the top of the ladder the supreme forms horde so i want to show
off now the supreme belial's very green uh chest here so you can see here i it doesn't open up right
away i have some options so the really cool thing about the supreme belial's horde is that you can set
it to mimic the reward drops of any other existing lair boss so let's say if you are trying to do durial
runs to get the special stuff that he has and you can set your belial to drop the durial loot and he will
do so at an enhanced rate so it's even better than if you just went to go fight durial specifically
yeah so if you're really targeted farmanine those specific uniques you get you know uh this durial
this version of uh of belial just gives you a much better chance of doing that as well yeah absolutely
and not just that in terms of like his value he also guarantees one ancestral unique drop uh per kill
and he's also a really great source of the infernal compasses so you know for if you want to you
empower your infernal horde runs and whatnot uh it's never a waste of time to go visit uh the belial
supreme at the top of the uh the ladder here yeah and this is in torment two and it all scales with
torment so exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we're so yeah what we're seeing in this footage is just
torment two so obviously like torment four you would get more loot out of it because you're it's a much more
more difficult challenge it is much for sure yeah it scales with the torment tears and also if we were in a
party in this example here we'd get even you know more chances of great stuff out of it as well that's
exactly right um all right cool well that is the lair key and the lair boss i'm just have a lot of
things to cover here yeah i know we want to talk a little bit about kind of the it's funny because
people saw it as ruben was on the map because they probably saw a a term like with apparitions and
everything right yeah there's a lot of teasing in this i know a lot of teasing this is a live build and
everything's going yeah it's exciting but one thing before we hop into the next day i do want to
re-establish so that everything that we just talked about as far as what we're introducing to
the lair boss system and all the mechanics new bosses and whatnot that is permanent that is just how
the system works now so everything is getting introduced in season eight but it's not leaving
beyond season eight it is just there it'll be an eternal so it will yeah it'll be an eternal that's
just how the system works what the next segment though is is all the seasonal specific stuff so
again as adam mentioned you might have seen some uh apparition incursion things pop up so let's get into
the first kind of a seasonal related content here oh the top says layer basket okay anyways um we do it
live uh apparition incursions uh apparition incursions is a new open world seasonal event uh to empower your
leveling journeys and also kind of just spread the narrative and uh dramas of belial is back on
sanctuary and he's spreading his own sense of you know twisted realities across the land uh he's always
in his efforts to try and plunge you know the world of sanctuary into his realm of lies and he's doing
it through this fast-paced boss rush style event that kind of takes the spirit of you know the open world
social boss play of the blood maiden and making a really cool kind of uh just really fast-paced you know
bam bam bam boss rush style events so i think we have some uh some footage here just to put some uh
yeah some visuals to it so you know this is an area of the world that belial's apparitions are kind of
overtaking um and throughout the course players are going to be defeating these apparitions to draw out
up to two of his apparition bosses this is pulled from a total of 10 potential apparition bosses so each
time you go through this you'll fight you know two of them kind of randomized so each time should be a
little bit different and all this is leading up to a showdown against belial himself so again it's
celebrating bosses it's three bosses per um event and the idea for this is that they're up pretty much
24 7 so we want to just encourage that you know hop on the boss train ride it to the end find the next
one and just you know go to your heart's content and you know celebration of bosses this season
really absolutely and what do you get for killing those bosses oh you're gonna get some cool stuff
colin let's go to the next slide um that kind of uh leads us into the collectible boss powers uh
our seasonal powers uh spoiled it right there it's already on the slide yeah we're fine so the theme
for uh the the powers theme for season eight is boss powers so belial being kind of like the uh the
illusionary character he is mimicry and whatnot in season eight players will be acquiring the ability
to steal and mimic the powers of up to 24 targeted bosses across sanctuary so we have 24 collectible powers
that are gathered from the first time kill of targeted bosses across the full content from
level one until the very top so you asked about you know what do the apparition bosses give you
they're aside from the loot and all that stuff they are also your first source of your first 10
uh boss powers that make up the magic tiers you can kind of see in this little chart here
graduating from the apparition uh
uh bosses you now go into the world bosses so each one of our three world bosses have a power
associated with them and then so to do each of our lair bosses capped off with lilith with her own
boss power that you can acquire like a ladder in the boss yeah it's definitely celebrating the
progression journey of bosses from you know the moment you log in to the moment that you're powerful
enough to take down lilith yeah um below you know below being kind of like the the star of the season
he's special he gets two powers because that's just how he rules yeah cheating yeah and i think you know
one of the cool things about this kind of structure it's a very structured power climb so little ambiguity
of like how do i get the wandering death's power well go fight and kill him it's just that nice little
structured journey that kind of is a nice little stamp collection just to reward each kind of a tier
progression that you make across your you know leveling and end game journeys um but that's not
just the coolest part of it in my opinion here is that it's also just how the powers work this season
so you can see that we have uh four slots the top slot and three little kind of like supporting slots so
the really cool thing is that each one of these powers have two sides to them they that activate
depending on which power slot you put them in so you can have up to one main uh one power you can
have up to one power slot into your main power slots or you can have up to three power slot into your
modifier slots and i just want to dive into this wandering deaths chest beam example here so if i were
to slot the wandering deaths power into the main power slot i would actually unlock the full representation
of his iconic chest beam power so the main powers is activating and unlocking the actual iconic power
that is representative of the boss we're going to show kind of a little bit of a showcase after this
but that's how that respective area of the power system works the modifier slots though are super are
cool and powerful in their own right though so let's say i don't necessarily need the wandering deaths
you know main power for whatever utility purposes i can still get value out of the fact that i
own it by slotting it into the modifier slots which activates kind of like the side b of it
which is more of a supporting thing so in this case it's your main power now it empowers your main
power to instantly execute non-boss enemies um you know when they're within a you know certain threshold
of life so it's not just uh you know 24 ways to kind of express your uh you know sense of power this
season it's 48 because each of these powers have you know kind of like two sides to them yeah it's really
like build your own boss power essentially yeah it's a lot of fun just kind of like mix match slot
around and see uh you know what what kind of a concoction you come up with and that's something
that i'm uh particularly interested in going to the ptr is like what are some of the favorite
combinations or and ideally what are the favorite combinations based off of the circumstance that
you're going into definitely yeah oh go ahead charles one thing i wanted to that i'm really excited
about the system is uh in previous um seasonal power systems we sometimes found as you got really high uh
you know paragon levels your build is like super powerful the the relative impact of of some of the
seasonal powers was a little lower they didn't really scale with you as well as we really wanted
to we we've done an update in in this season where these boss powers are going to uh scale with your
paragon level as you're as you're leveling up and so they actually are going to get more powerful as you
get more powerful right so the exact number uh that you as soon as you unlock it it you know maybe is not
the most powerful thing but as you're you're powering up it's it's still going to be relevant to your
build at every stage of your progression that's really good i like the fact that the powers don't
kind of just live on their own little island like they get ingrained into the other systems that we're
engaging with um so yeah so that's a high level of the of the boss powers for season eight and i want
to toss it back to ruben for just kind of a little bit of a live showcase of them hey derek thanks for
all that that was great man yeah i'm excited what do you got for us uh well i get the fun job of
showcasing all these powers today but i must confess i got my smoothie so i'm a little jacked up
today so i'll try not to talk to you i'm thrilled i'm thrilled let's go ahead and open up uh our
inventory here and you'll notice on the left side a familiar tab is our seasonal tab which is boss powers
so from this tab is where you'll be kind of interacting with your powers throughout the season
like derek mentioned you can drag and drop them equip them on the fly there's no penalty
i think the team and everybody wants you to experiment and have fun with the builds
you can also upgrade them by hovering over them there's a corresponding button here on pc it's f
so go ahead and push that to upgrade them and yeah so uh the top slot is your main slot like derek
mentioned this is where your main powers go and all the bottom ones are your modifier slots so right
here um you know derek's favorite was the wandering death's chest beam so as a modifier right you can
execute enemies but as soon as you drag it over here boom now it's a channeled ability and you'll
notice right away it's a prominent beam um yeah it works well with channeled abilities it only works
with channeled abilities actually and it's kind of cool with densive knives because you can uh adjust
and do these micro adjustments to kind of maximize the effect on your target just to keep it on them a
little bit longer yeah and as you can kind of tell we're not necessarily going for subtlety in terms of
the expression of these powers this season i'm dying someone in chat's like goku oh my god
all right i also we'll just we'll call it real quick just one thing i absolutely love is just the
uh the animations of the ui itself and you know you slot these little like eyeball socket eyeball
powers into the little eye sockets and it blinks and um yeah it just is kind of just fun across
the board just engaging with this and pops yeah so what do we got next uh the next one i want to
showcase is lilis wind of hate just because probably most of us have died to this before
her spike ability from the ground and it works on almost every skill so you can definitely you can
see as soon as i dash here i get the spikes with barrage you get the spikes so you can slot in almost
every build and have fun with it even dance of knives really cool ability there let's see what else we
got another fun one there's a transformative ability is uh durials burrow so it completely changes your
evade skill and you burrow underground you deal damage when you go in to the ground and when you
exit but the real cool thing is you become immune while underground and you can control the direction
oh that's awesome is awesome yeah that's one of my absolute favorite i love that one you can stand
still if you like or whatever and it scales as you get more evade charges you get more burrows so i'm sure
there's a lot of uh especially adding three new bosses with all kinds of crazy effects you know you can now
dodge them a little bit easier which is great i'm sure there's some good use cases for that yeah and
even just even just right there i want to just chime in and just say that you know we showed off a power
that procs off of the evade we showed one that procs off channeling and one that procs off any skills
like one of the goals going into the design of these powers was to just remove any ambiguity about how
do i actually proc it we wanted to make it as utility focused and straightforward as possible
so that players can really easily easily digest and how they work it into their builds yeah that's
a great point um urvar's bombs is probably my personal favorite as i like making builds and
interesting builds this definitely supports ultimate builds and as you can see on the screen here it
lowers your cooldown by five seconds which is great and gives you a nice damage component to kind of top
off on it so we're playing rogue and uh death trap is an ultimate ability so as soon as i pop it you'll
see urvar's bombs kind of shoot out and you get that lower cooldown effect as well so it's great
boom and you get two death traps i wonder how he's doing that that's that's on me that's on me guys uh
yeah all the teasing on the stream uh and finally before they play the walk off music i think i could
showcase uh let's do grigor's lightning square so if you notice lilith skill had like a slight cooldown
this one scales with your build really well so the more you can cast core skills the more you get these
iconic kind of lightning strike panels shoot out from your character uh so you can imagine you
can just go full thunder thunder god here the whole time with your builds so yeah i think that's all i
can showcase today but i appreciate the time no thank you that was awesome um yeah so again those are
just like a kind of a sneak peek at just a handful of the powers again uh throughout the course of the
ptr you'll get to you know experiment engage with all of them and again looking forward to the feedback
and just uh you know just general notes of how you incorporate into your builds and what really
excites you um so i think that's pretty much the wrap up for all the content coming in season eight
uh that persists beyond in yeah yeah all the uh the season eight stuff that will be available in ptr for
players to actually jump into um we're still going to be talking about a few more things as we get
closer to season eight uh with the launch of um the actual season itself so uh derek thank you so much for
walking us through everything um and of course with a new season and a new ptr we have a lot of
changes that are coming to classes specifically like the rogue which we saw so many things yeah
we can just skip yeah we'll just skip the road there's other classes to talk about yeah so uh charles
over here is actually going to go through all the class changes that players will be able to experience
and test out during the ptr yeah of course i mean there's tons of new bosses to fight so how are you
going to fight them right so let's talk about some class updates that are coming uh first i want to talk
about some updates that are going to affect all classes in some way these are kind of a bit more
generic uh updates um so talking about ultimate scaling this is something that we introduced in
uh in season seven the current live season where uh as you get to rank five of the ultimate skills
some of them had mechanics that allowed you to crank up their damage by building different stats
right so if you got more damage while fortified then your blood wave is going to do more damage for
instance uh we think that's really cool it enabled a lot of very powerful builds a lot of
very powerful builds um and so we're looking at uh ensuring that those don't like really eclipse
every other option in the game we still love that those are powerful builds we love that you're
playing them we don't want them to be the only option and so with that in mind we're we're looking
at putting a cap on that scaling you can scale them up to 200 bonus damage which is still a lot
you're still doing you know like triple damage um but we just want to make sure it doesn't get
completely out of control with um all the new stats and and some of the scaling coming in from some
of the seasonal powers uh that could potentially lead those to be uh you know crowding out other
options of gameplay uh additionally additionally we're looking at uh crowd control this is something
i talked about on our last uh campfire chat about how we're really looking at the moment to moment
combat of our game you know like what are you doing like ever like one second to the next and one
thing that came up a lot was uh sometimes enemies just randomly get crowd controlled they randomly are
frozen or stunned and you a lot of this comes from some of the what we call incidental crowd control
as in lucky hit crowd control effects or anything that involves not like oh i pressed a button now
they're stunned right um and and we we noticed like hey we got a lot of these effects across the
game in many different places and so we looked at really toning those down specifically in the generic
spaces i know fist of fate is one of a very popular uh unique item right now for for many reasons uh one
of them was that uh that kind of free crowd control but that's something that we think wasn't really
promoting the best moment to moment combat and most engaging flow um so that particular affix has been
changed to uh lucky hit uh apply vulnerable but a lot of the other um uh identity of fist of fate is
still there as well so it still has you know wide ranges on things it still does random damage and a lot
of lucky hit chance as well yeah and this this change really puts the value of frost nova and ground stomp and
it sort of makes those more valuable and satisfying right yeah so so if you really want to get those
kind of crowd control effects like it's going to be a build choice you're going to have to consciously
do it and you're going to like like know when it's happening it's not just oh they randomly got stunned
and you know if they didn't get some maybe you got hit and and that never felt good when it was just
kind of purely random yeah yeah uh additionally this is a something that uh the keen-eyed among you might
have spied when we were looking at some other stuff we've done a bit of a naming pass on some of the
damage over time effects um this is no functional change this is just a naming thing um where we
have things like a physical damage and when it's physical damage over time we call it bleeding uh
and when it's poison we call it poisoning for instance uh we didn't previously have names for shadow
lightning or cold damage over time uh we would just call it like from shadow damage over time affected
enemies which was an absolute mouthful um so we've got new uh common terms uh shadow damage over time
will be called corrupting damage lightning damage over time is shocking damage and cold damage over
time which we saw with the wandering death chest beam is called frostbite damage uh so that's just a
terminology thing it still relates uh to those base damage types same as always uh it's just a
terminology update cleans up the tool tips absolutely yeah all right so let's get on to some of the actual
class updates uh starting oh we'll just go alphabetically with the barbarian all right so our focus
on barbarian this season uh is about uh primarily about barbarians core fantasy of being physical
and hitting enemies with a big weapon right um in the in the past couple seasons a lot of the meta
builds around barbarian have focused around things like earthquakes or dust devils which are really cool
and and fun but i think they um we we got some feedback that hey i don't really feel like i'm i'm
hitting enemies with my big weapon i'm just making a tornado that hits them which is not maybe uh me
fulfilling the the fantasy that you want out of a barbarian your core skill isn't the cool thing
it's the thing that the core skill spawns right yeah right and that's um it's cool that those exist
uh but we want to make sure we're also catering to to that you know heavy hitter kind of fantasy
and so a lot of the updates this season are focused around that uh specifically updates to double swing
core skill and the twin strikes unique to make that a bit more impactful to actually be hitting
uh whirlwind as well um that's getting a a buff and a rework with uh gore's uh it's it's unique
gore's devastating grips um and then the new unique and legendary this season really talked to mighty
throw in particular and make that just like the biggest hitting thing let's take a look at those
uh uniques and the unique and legendary here so we've got the bane of ajaden this is a unique glove item
and it says that every 12 seconds your next mighty throw is going to detonate all of its pulses
instantly you know normally mighty throw like pulses over time it's going to do them all at once and
deal massively increased damage and that's going to pair up very well with the new legendary aspect
of delayed extinction which causes both mighty throw and steel grasp to gain multiplicative bonus damage
rather than cooldown from cooldown reduction so if you've got cooldown reduction on your gear or on
the bane of ajaden for instance that's not going to actually reduce the cooldown it's going to be
a multiplicative scaler for these skills and so that now you've got a new problem to solve right
you you uh can't cast these skills quite as often but when you do they're going to hit super hard
and so we've got a video clip of it just deleting a screen so you walk up and they're all gone
one hit that's all it takes because you've got all these multipliers on your one big hit
but of course because it doesn't benefit from cooldown reduction that cooldown is going to be
pretty much locked at that 12 second mark and so you're going to have to find some other way to kind
of fill the gap in there and you've got a new challenge for your build to overcome
i'm hoping to see it like uh belial get decked by this i think it is possible that you're you're
gonna you're gonna melt some bosses with some really big hits it's a great finishing move oh yeah
all right let's take a look at the druid so for the druid i want to talk a little bit about
uh one of the meta builds right now is uh revolts around cataclysm and and kind of uh
snapshotting issues that come up with that and so uh for those of you who don't know what what
snapshotting basically means is uh for cataclysm which is one of their ultimate skills that has a
duration so you press the button it's summons a storm around you that lasts for some amount of time
and if you get a lot of that cooldown reduction and you can cast cataclysm a second time before the
first one expires currently on on the live game uh the the second cast of cataclysm will keep all of
the bonuses and like bonus damage effects or guaranteed overpowers or whatever that was
affecting the first one and that was definitely not intended that is not how uh we wanted that to
work we didn't want bonuses from one cast kind of instance to carry over to the next cast now this can
only happen in uh situations where you get that lot of cooldown uh but it was kind of promoting this
gameplay where it's very feast or famine if you successfully kind of snapshot all the buffs uh
this build is insanely powerful and if you mess it up or you don't get the snapshot quite right
you're actually really weak and that led to to unintuitive gameplay and uh this really um big divide
between the best and the optimal and like kind of the average normal case scenario uh so we're
addressing that where we don't really want to to promote that uh between two different cast
snapshotting yeah we don't like snapshotting in general right yeah the the kind of snapshotting
where you you are persisting things between uh different cast instances or equipping gear and then
unequipping it to to maintain a bonus those are are snapshotting things that we don't think it
promotes healthy gameplay uh it's unintuitive in a lot of cases you need to read a guide and follow an
exact checklist to do it um that's not something that that we think is is good for the game there
are some cases where um you know with cataclysm you know giving the bonus to that whole cat that first
time you cast it that it you might say it's kind of snapshots for the duration of cataclysm but that's
intended where it says your next cast does something that's what we want but we don't want that to persist on
to multiple casts or or through uh basically infinitely um so that's that's one thing that
we're adjusting on druid um but we're also looking at at promoting other play styles as well we think
uh that build is is fun but there's there's other ways to play druid as well uh specifically with
stoneburst that's the uh the earth core skill uh it was kind of a channeled skill which um from a lot
of our channeled skills they are not allowed to overpower um but with stoneburst particularly we
have reworked one of its legendary items to allow it to overpower when you detonate it at maximum size
which is really cool and opens up to new build possibilities for stoneburst and finally want to
talk about uh the new unique uh gathlin's birthright uh this is a let's take a look at it on screen here
um it's in a similar vein to tempest roar and vasilius prayer where it is a unique helm that is very
transformational but rather than talking to werewolves or werebear built it's talking to human
form builds if you just you don't want to uh you don't want to embrace the wilds quite as much you
want to stay in your human form gathlin's birthright is going to be the unique helm for you it says while
you're in human form critically striking enemies with your nature magic skills will grant you anima of
the forest for 10 seconds and when you get great uh whenever you gain anima of the forest you are
infused with bonus key passives perfect storm and earth and might so if you have this and you have
another key passive you can potentially have up to three key passives active at once which is not
something we've ever done before in diablo 4. that's nutty and i love that it's on the helm so if you
really want to be a human druid which historically you know hasn't been as great as like werewolf for
example this is the home for you yeah this is exactly uh exactly that it's in a similar spot as like
hey this is build defining in the way that tempest roar is for werewolves we want this to be the build
defining helm for human form druids uh additionally aspect of impending deluge that empowers your storm
strike which is probably pretty useful with this human form nature magic build uh which will cause
your storm strike to deal more and also increase damage they take from your other skills for a time
i think we've got a picture of this or a video of this in action where you've got your uh druid it's got
you uh you need 200 stacks of anima of the force which sounds like a lot but it triggers on every
hit so in most combat situations you actually stack it up pretty quick and see once you get this online
you're going to be empowered with earth and might and with perfect storm and with nature's fury you have
all of this power and the idea of three three passes going at once is the the key passes is crazy yeah
yeah boss power slapped on top of that too oh yeah it is it is a lot uh when you when you get this empowered
state all right moving on to uh one of my favorite classes the necromancer um so necromancer was
probably the talk of the current season season seven uh with blood wave i know we've mentioned
it a few times on stream uh blood wave really good um we we've talked about how we uh we're going to
look at ultimate scaling so maybe it won't scale up with the bonus damage at least not to the the same
level that it had before we're going to put a cap on that um we also just think we we generally overshot
the mark on uh the the unique item the kesemi's legacy which really like you get this item and
suddenly you're a god it it just had so much power in one spot um and and we like a bit more of that
progression that colin was alluding to before about that zero to hero journey and when you have one
item that is you equip it and it's over like you're as powerful as you ever need to be um that really
shortcuts that journey and really makes it feel um less satisfying than than we want uh so we're
looking taking a look at reducing the power of that unique in particular as well some other adjustments
to blood wave uh we do want blood wave uh builds to still be powerful and still be an option if you
like that play style we just don't want it to be the s plus plus tier that it was in the past
additionally we're taking a look at blood lance this is a core skill that has historically been very
good in in multi-target kind of uh clearing out uh pit runs or dungeon situations but then you run up
into a boss which hey we're fighting a lot of bosses this season yeah uh and it suddenly falls really
flat because its core mechanic is about uh like arcing damage between enemies and if there's only one
enemy what are you doing here right um so with this update to blood lance it's going to uh still
maintain some of that fantasy where it arcs the damage between enemies but if you're hitting a target
who's already lanced it's going to do a massive amount more damage so it's a much better in single
target situations and much more viable for bossing and finally the new legendary and unique for the
season talks to minions so let's take a look at sanguivar blade of zeer the unique two-handed sword
so this weapon uh will empower your summons so so your minions and your army of the dead to affect
enemies with vampiric curse now for those of you played back in season two uh vampiric curse was a
mechanic that we introduced in in the season of blood where you affect enemies with it and as you
kill them you kind of collect their soul and then you can unleash these souls they they kind of run out
from you and explode and it's really satisfying moment and we we put that on a handful of legendary
aspects but now all of your summons will affect enemies with vampiric curse and you can unleash them
with army of the dead and when you do that the this uh the souls from vampiric curse and army of the
dead itself will deal massively increased damage scaling with how many souls you've collected
it's huge i love minion necro it's like my favorite oh yeah yeah this this is really cool um for for
army of the dead and and minion necro um to just really be that that impactful moment of of summoning
an army of of uh of skeletons to just eviscerate the enemies and additionally uh aspect of service
and sacrifice i love playing with this one this one feels so good to play your your skeleton warriors
explode on death dealing a massive chunk of physical damage to surrounding enemies and to help make sure
they die they lose 25 life per second while in combat so you're going to be needing to resummon
them quite often but when you do hey it's good because they're going to be detonating for this massive
chunk at the end and additionally while you're resummoning all your warriors your mages are going to be
super tanky they're going to take 90 less damage and deal massively increased damage so you're going
to have your mages up pretty much all the time and you're going to be focusing on resummoning the
warriors to to run in there and explode and and do their damage that way that's awesome it's a really
clever way to make it feel like you're constantly summoning and you have your back line of uh mages just
obliterating yeah it's great let's take a look at sanguivar blade of zeer in action here uh oh no sorry this
is actually service of and sacrifice um so you've got your skeleton warriors the the skirmishers they
run up there um and then here's blade of zeer right you get all those like skeleton warriors running out
when you activate army of the dead not you you just get the the normal ones that are are running around
but then they all uh you unleash a stream of them uh straight from you uh with uh the uh with the
with the sanguivar really impactful um ultimate skill there yeah army of the dead is just so
underutilized so i'm so happy to see it come back into the fold it's great all right um next up we've
got the one we've been teasing for a bit thank you ruben uh the rogue let's take a look at uh the idea
with rogue so as you probably guessed the theme of rogue this season is looking at trap builds uh right
with both death trap and poison trap in a way uh historically poison trap has been kind of
underrepresented um death trap builds have been quite popular pretty powerful and and a lot of
fun to play uh poison trap uh kind of fell by the wayside a little bit um it had a number of issues
that we're looking to address this season um to really promote poison trap as a viable standalone build
and uh what we're seeing um from from ruben was the scoundrels leather rework now this is a unique
chest item that's been in the game for a while it was about traps in the past uh we've done a rework
this season where when you cast a trap uh or rather every 10 seconds when you cast the trap you're
going to get a bonus death trap so you could cast poison trap or caltrops or death trap itself and then
you get a second death trap and when you actually cast uh the death trap active button you're going to
to kind of jump or teleport to that position so you can just instantly get uh get into the fray there
oh that's cool yeah so it you know rogues are all about mobility and jumping around the battlefield
and and uh doing that kind of thing this is just another tool in their arsenal to really jump in
put the death trap down which groups up some enemies and then they're ready for you to slaughter
there um but let's take a look at the new items that talk to poison trap specifically uh the bands of
icarus rose these are unique gloves that says uh your poison trap is which normally has a nine second
duration it's always going to do its full damage over three seconds instead so it's much shorter
duration but higher dps and it's always going to benefit from all of its upgrades you know that
enhancement and those those modifications you just get all of them you don't need to put skill points
in and normally the the two choices are mutually exclusive you get both with these and they're going
to be even more powerful additionally poison trap will now also benefit from your combo points if you're
using those it's going to have no cooldown during the inner sight if you're using inner sight and if
you're using preparation its cooldown is going to be reduced by the preparation trigger so previously
poison trap didn't really interact with any of these three mechanics very well and now it benefits from
whichever one you want that's so cool so it really makes it more like a core skill something i can
work into my rotation oh yeah yeah you're going to be wanting to use this very often with this uh with
this unique and then the aspect of contamination as many builds that focus around poison on
rogue often uh want to build critical strike damage because that's really good with the poison
imbuement poison trap um now also can scale up with some critical strike chance so it uh with aspect of
contamination it unleashes a poison burst when it detonates like kind of initial upfront hit and then
if that burst critically strikes which you know if you're building a lot of crit chance it probably will
or if you hit a lot of enemies then you're going to deal increased poison damage for a duration which
will of course increase the rest of the duration of the poison trap and uh this is probably my
favorite clip here let's get a clip of this one um right so you you uh apply poison trap which uh
it's going to throw two of them out and one of its upgrades knocks down enemies and because it's
increased it knocks them down for quite a while and so they just uh take a little nap in your poison
traps uh i don't recommend it but hey if it any if they do they take a ton of poison damage i love the
knockdown animation of this kind of enemy yeah this guy uh just just falls right down
lay down i guess the face his face is in it his face plants and uh and then succumbs to the poison
so it's awesome all right uh moving on we've got our sorceress uh so the sorceress class uh definitely
is one of the ones uh currently on season seven that i think didn't have any of these real big
outlier builds that we'd kind of talked about some of the the highest highs come from like the blood
necro um or or uh the the druid with the snapshotting uh cataclysm uh and i think i definitely want to
acknowledge that you know sorceress maybe didn't have some of those those real outliers this season
and they were maybe felt like they were a bit behind of those so as we talked about with other
classes we're definitely looking at bringing those outlier builds down a notch to to bring them kind
of uh back to to the norm of of some of the other builds so they're not so far ahead um but for
sorceress we're looking at at improving some of the uh the quality of life and some of the the
interactions between some of their mechanics like crackling energy meteors and meteorites and making
sure they scale well with the build um like crackling energy will now have the shock skill
tag so if you're building up damage for shock skills or some of the other synergies there those now
interact with your crackling energy and additionally with meteor and meteorites they're not going to be
able to scale with each other's damage which helps builds just be a bit more cohesive and and feel more
uh robustly supported um that being said i think where sorceress has been um in season seven is um in
terms of like its power progression and and the the relative strength of its builds uh amongst each
other is is more of the the closer to the ideal state of where we envision all classes ending up
um we we recognize that that they are kind of a bit lower uh than other classes in season seven
um but we're looking at bringing them up a little bit with improved quality of life and build options
and making sure that some of the outlier builds that's really skewing that perception are are being
brought to be um to to bring them close together yeah and create some more harmony between the classes
exactly yeah yeah and i think this is something that we're actively looking at again to the point of
early in the season if things aren't really performing to the level of our expectation and it doesn't feel
good then those are things that we're going to buff and sorceress is a great example of like what
we're going to be really looking at yeah yeah and and we want to do that in ways that that make
we don't just want to slap on a 50x scaler on sorceress we want to make sure that the builds feel
cohesive and coherent in a way that makes a lot of sense um and so that's what all the bulk of our
focus is for sort uh this season uh specifically want to talk a little bit about um ice shards uh that's
what the uh the new unique uh is going to be uh working with here let's take a look at the unique
the hail of virglass uh this is a unique helm that's going to empower your ice shards to spread out
rather than shoot in kind of a straight line that kind of rapid fire uh it's now going to be a spread
pattern you can hit more enemies with it and you get bonus shards and you're going to be dealing
increased damage for every time and ice shards damages an enemy and it's going to stack up uh so it
takes a lot of stacks you need to be spamming ice shards you need to be hitting a lot but once you
do it it unleashes a lot of bonus uh damage and also it just makes the skill in my opinion a lot more
usable right i like the spread pattern a whole lot um unless you hit wider screen and you can kind of
like shotgun enemies if you get nice and close to them that's cool and uh shivering aspect a new uh
legendary aspect here uh enemies are going to take increased damage based on how much they're chilled
or staggering now historically uh some of the the frost sorcs or some of the other builds that
were heavy on those crowd control effects sometimes they really struggled into to bosses which hey
bosses are the theme of the season it's very appropriate um so so we're making sure that that
some of these new effects that that uh scale based on the crowd control effects also work against bosses
so this will kind of uh take how much stagger you've built up on the boss and also give you a bonus
damage based on that uh so so really being cognizant of hey let's make sure this works in the situations
you want it to and it's not night and day oh i'm clearing trash mobs and then i hit the boss and
and you just feel so different uh we want to make sure that's a bit smoother of an experience between
the two uh ways of playing all right let's take a look at the hail of virglass with these new ice shards
in action right so they they fire out pretty quick they fire out in a nice spread and uh you can
clear through whole packs of skeletons with with a single cast here multi-shot oh yeah
multi-shot with ice shards yeah oh yeah all right and moving on to our final class here the spirit born
uh so the spirit born uh was in a pretty good state i mean similar to to sorceress where it didn't have
those crazy overpowered builds but we think it's it's in a relatively um healthy spot and we're just
looking at empowering new build options and making uh tighter synergies between the builds and and
giving you some new tools to play with uh with that in mind we took a look at rushing claw it's one of
my favorite skills on the spirit born but never really found its way into any of the most popular
builds um in the past couple seasons since spirit born was released um and we we've updated the the uh
the two upgrade choices to be uh kind of transformative it's kind of a if you pick one upgrade the
the current one um russian clause has four charges and so when you use a charge you kind of quickly
dash through an enemy and so you have four charges you can spam it four times real quick um the other
upgrade now uh has been reworked where it gains even more charges it gains 12 charges but using it consumes
all the charges so really it has just one but for every charge that it consumes it deals massively
increased damage and it hits a wider area so now gaining cooldown reduction or gaining more charges
actually just increases your damage output and and it promotes a very different play style uh for this
so you get kind of an option you can choose the original version uh which is still very powerful and
very cool uh or you can choose the new upgrade and kind of spend all your charges at once do a big kind
of damage cooldown and then work on building up those charges again to deal even more uh additionally we
we've looked at uh storm feathers and specifically how they interact with the new unique item the sunbird's
gorget which i think we've got a a picture of right here so the sunbird's gorget is a new unique amulet
this really uh works to synergize with the eagle and jaguar builds so it says picking up a storm feather
which you can create in many different ways will form a firestorm around you for eight seconds that
deals fire damage and every additional storm feather that you pick up is going to intensify
this firestorm it's going to make it grow in size up to a maximum and then it's going to increase its
damage output for as many storm feathers as you can spawn this firestorm is going to get more intense
but it only lasts for eight seconds so intensifying it or picking up more storm feathers it's not going
to extend the duration so it's kind of locked to that eight second duration and then it'll reset so you
really want to collect as many storm feathers as possible in eight seconds and then and then it
restarts and also that this firestorm is considered an igua an eagle jaguar and storm feather skill so
you've got lots of options for how you want to increase this damage through your other talent
choices or your itemization uh you got lots of options for for how to work this into a build in
either eagle or jaguar or both and uh following up on the theme with rushing claw we've got the new rip and
tear aspect where rushing claw is going to deal increased damage and is empowered based on how
many charges you had when you cast it so if you're taking the upgrade that gives you 12 charges it's
probably always going to be with four plus and so it's going to strike an additional time but if
you're choosing the option where you spend each charge as you go it's going to go through a bit of
a cycle here you're going to get an additional strike then it's going to get a guaranteed crit then it's
going to get a guaranteed overpower and when you just have one charge left it's going to give you a nice
chunky heel to help keep you in the fight nice there's a ton of versatility in there yeah yeah
lots of different ways to play and it works great with with either way uh that russian claw now works
all right let's take a look at the sunbird's gorget in action here right so you're moving along
you're picking up tons of these feathers and the firestorm around you just grows in intensity
uh you've got lots of different ways to to scale it up and it provides a nice kind of passive aoe
around you as you're picking them up and you're really going to want to make sure you're you're
kind of uh thinking about exactly how your character is moving to make sure picking up as
many of these storm feathers as possible to maximize your damage output
all right that's um that's a lot we got a lot of new class content coming for every class uh we did
get through all of them um but yeah i'm really looking forward to seeing all the new builds that uh
that these empower how they modify old existing builds and and all the interesting combinations that i'm
sure all of you will test out on the ptr and find out the most absolutely broken thing and let me
know about it yes please let us know if you find something absolutely broken which i'm sure you will
so thank you again charles uh for walking us through all the different class changes again this is uh we
do plan on having uh patch notes along with the blog related to everything uh tied to ptr so there's
other changes that we didn't actually cover off in here uh that will be on the uh diablo4.com immediately
after the stream um so everyone can actually check it out inspect it you know do their theory
crafting and everything uh related to that of course with ptr uh we kind of want to know when ptr
actually begins uh ptr is starting next tuesday uh and this is of course ptr on pc battle net uh so
players will be able to jump in uh starting on the 11th and it'll run for a week there i will note that
players actually will be able to also pre-download the ptr uh the day prior so around monday afternoon
here in california um i translate that using some sort of time tool uh that will be when players will
be able to uh pre-download so it'll be about a day beforehand um one thing to note is um of course the
boost vendor uh mrak will be available which will be dancing in in town for everyone but one thing we did
want to note is that the boost themselves will be available probably two days after the ptr actually
begins um the reason behind this is actually a little bit tied to how season seven performed
uh one thing we allowed players to do was immediately boost um the second they got into ptr and we really
didn't get that whole entire flow as we were kind of going through the headhunt and things like that so
we also just want to hear your feedback on the leveling process right this is why we run the ptr
uh we really want to hear your thoughts on how the sort of uh more uniform leveling feels how the
legendary drop rates feel so that is really valuable to us uh for launching a really awesome season eight
exactly yeah and so after a couple days mrak will be more than happy to take your paragon levels to uh
insane numbers so ptr boost will be available just a couple days after uh that one other thing i do want
to note is um we will of course have our forums available and online uh for ptr that is the best
place to actually provide feedback of course we do look in other places such as reddit discord etc
but i will say like the forums is kind of we turn them on specifically like a ptr section so please put
feedback in there because we are constantly checking in there for uh any notes feedback from players on that
end uh one other note is within the ptr you guys may see a term called the reliquary uh that may just
kind of pop up uh here and there and you we haven't talked about the reliquary nor will the blog later
today actually be talking about the reliquary um i will say that you guys will hear more about the
reliquary before the start of season eight in itself um but for right now uh ignore it i don't know turn a
blind eye i don't know uh but it is a um rework of our battle pass system that we're doing we're
trying to uh we we've heard a lot of comments from players related to the battle pass trying to make
it a little bit more customizable for people especially for rewards that they're looking for
so we'll have a detailed breakdown of what the reliquary is before season eight so uh looking forward
to kind of sharing that uh before we actually kick off this season and i know i have a lot i'm trying
to get through all my stuff and i know it's like i'm hungry um the um uh the last thing we do want
to talk about is i've gotten asked a million times about this and i've even seen it in chat uh and
it's related to a roadmap uh for diablo 4 and i will say that uh we are actively working on a roadmap that
we can share with you all uh which is great because it gives you and and everyone a a uh opportunity to
kind of see more of like the future vision of what's coming for diablo 4. um we do plan on actually
having this roadmap out before season eight um so we're really excited to share it so as soon as we
actually do have that available we of course will you'll you'll hear it everywhere uh we will be on
every single microphone and megaphone out there showcasing uh what the the roadmap is and you've
probably seen roadmap if you're curious like what what does a roadmap entail you've probably seen some of
our uh fellow uh teams here at blizzard such as like diablo immortal or like world of warcraft they've
actually posted uh these more public facing roadmaps and that's something that we want to do here
so that you guys have that uh ability of being able to see what what's coming up for diablo 4 and and
more exciting news related to it so um i know we have q a we want to jump into q a here really quickly
uh so if you guys do have any questions or anything of course we have our chat available on
uh the twitch uh link for diablo so feel free to jump in and and ask any questions um i know we
uh we always queue it up with one question specifically and uh do we have a question slide
here there we go uh how does party play work with layer bosses we kind of covered this a little bit but
i don't know if you guys want to go into specifically more details on this um yeah i can jump into that so
when you are fighting the layer bosses uh in a party and the horde the horde spawns when you open the
horde we essentially do a bonus chance for an extra drop based on the amount of party players
uh party play so if you're in a party of four and you open up that horde it's going to guarantee an
extra unique item so it scales with the amount of parties or party members you have and it's always
a good time you know when you get together with people awesome um i'm like i'm so unprepared all right
let me look through the questions here as uh people are dropping in questions i have a team of people
dropping questions to it if you're ever wanting to know how we do this we just have a google doc and
we're copying and pasting questions from chat into there so um very high tech like super high tech um
let's see this is from skulm tv any plans to place a blacksmith or vendor near the boss rooms
to help people quickly salvage clear inventory without having to go into town
um i think this is something that we can definitely uh take away and consider especially with the revamp flow
that's definitely something that's interesting one thing that the revamp flow does i will touch on
is the amount of chain bossing really requires you to have a lot more materials if anything you know
sort of some philosophy here is we've heard a lot of feedback that it feels mandatory to play some of
these bosses in a party just because chain bossing is so lucrative and we do expect some amount of the
chain bossing to come down a little bit because a lot more of the resources are being consumed when
opening those chests so um it's not a direct answer to your question i think it's an interesting
idea but i do think the amount of chain bossing and required trips and flow breaks to go back to
town from some of this bossing is going to come down a little bit especially been playing if you've
been playing a ton of party awesome uh question from uh fan 27 uh q a or sorry he wrote diablo q a and i
just read that out loud uh any chance we will have to redo strongholds and waypoints on every character
every single season uh i can answer that one too yeah this is something uh i definitely experience
it's always a big pain in the ass where it's like oh there's some cool bounty or apparition incursion but
i have to go get the waypoint um it's something the team has been talking about there's no concrete
plans today which i know is disappointing but it's something we know is a problem and something we 100
want to tackle in the near future awesome uh jokums uh says uh would you this is actually a question
that um you know we were talking about that might actually come up but like would you consider adding
the frog from which powers uh in season seven as a permanent companion skill for druids and uh at the
moment i can say we're not uh for that specifically but uh it is a thing that i think we we didn't really
clarify in regards to what from season seven is kind of like for sure staying over um i i will say
like the the witch powers uh are are most definitely like something that um aren't carrying over completely
over to to to the future seasons but one thing in regards to at least the the um tree of whispers
is that like we have a bunch of new npcs there we redid the layout there that is uh made that as a hub that
doesn't feel like i'm just going for the tree and i have to like immediately leave uh it's it's made
it as like a all-encompassing place that you can most definitely tap into from that end yeah oh go
ahead i can speak a bit to you know the seasonal powers i as we said that a lot of those witchcraft
powers are specific to season seven that is true they are not necessarily coming back um in in season
eight but but we do hear that feedback right i think they got a really positive reception a lot of like
the poison frog one of my favorites you know fire bats and all kinds of other things that are um very
visually flashy and just a lot of fun to play with uh we hear that and and that definitely helps us
to inform like making future content in the past we've done that where we've taken some some favorite
seasonal mechanics put them on items to return i can't speak to any particular plans but just know
that we do hear this feedback and it'll definitely help us to to help craft um content in the future
um we got a lot of questions related to ptr because i know um as i mentioned this is a pc battle net ptr and
there there's a few people like um kim from canadia and i can't read this because the the text color is
so just jarring uh but the um uh we've gotten a lot of questions related to ptr being on pc battle net
asking like hey is there any plans of bringing it to console maybe steam i'll say the reason why
pc battle net works best for us is that um battle net is a platform that is housed here at blizzard and is
the the processes of getting builds up there making like any type of change especially for ptr where
we're in a smaller window uh and we may need to change something really quickly uh just it gives
us more flexibility and allows us to be able to change those things really really smoothly um i know
with other platforms and everything there's more processes involved for for good reason because they
you know they have more checks and balances and everything um so it makes it a little bit more
difficult on our end to do some of those fast iterations that we may need with ptr so in the
foreseeable future right now we see pc battle net as being kind of the home for ptrs when we do and
end up testing anything um question from uh my computer is telling me to update it's been telling me for
weeks um don't hate me it uh chris mate says will the lair bosses have resilience slash damage reduction
that the world bosses have to ensure that they just don't get one shot too fast with some classes
or builds trivial trivial trivial i did that i can't talk today trivializing yeah i can't even talk i
think this is a great question it's something we actually talk about on the team uh a bunch and you
know from our perspective uh adding something like resilience would sort of devalue that power
progression like we feel like it sort of disservices that sort of zero to hero once belial was really hard but
now i've gotten so strong i can just crush him that said we do think that the level of one-shotting
bosses that has been happening is a little bit too much there isn't enough of a journey to get to a
point where i can just stomp on varshaw or i can stomp on the pennant tonight um so what we have done
is like derek mentioned earlier in the stream we've massively buffed a lot of these bosses like so much so
they were kind of like try it on the ptr and see uh but a lot of these bosses should present more of a
journey to getting to a place where you can really stomp on them throughout the torment tiers
um even uber lilith herself has been um or i don't remember what we actually call it echo
echo we just keep calling her we're literally now it's just stuck yeah um has seen quite a buff
and that should mean that that journey to getting to a place where you're really farming some of
these bosses is a lot more fulfilling but it's longer also you're not just like walking into
torment one and one-shotting varshaw yeah and that kind of ties into what i talked about with some of the
outlier builds that we're just like blood wave macro prime example of of being something where
you get one item and then suddenly you can one shot everything uh it's really not it doesn't promote
the best gameplay like it's just like it's fun for a little bit to go in and one shot everything but
um that's that's something we we think it's it's much more engaging to to have a little bit of back
and forth and you're not just going in and stomping them but you are you do feel powerful uh feel some
power progression and as you get more powerful and more gear and more paragon levels you do get
more powerful and becomes easier to overcome these challenges and then you start feeling that real
powerful stuff as you really complete your build yeah and i'll also say like i think part of how we
originally set up the boss ladder it really did encourage the one-shotting behavior right like if
you have to pay materials to fight this boss why would you ever fight the boss when it's actually a
challenge right you would only fight it when it's really difficult but the changes that we've made have
really sort of you know in a fun way i'm hoping uh this plays out that you can sort of maybe get a
cheeky run in on varchan when maybe he's really hard but you get a really powerful unique um because
you don't have to risk anything anymore when to actually summon him yeah i think it also kind of
speaks to just the approach of injecting challenge across the lair bosses like we discussed you know
we could just do straight stat boosts and that would definitely resolve it but within season eight the
team took the extra opportunity to also just inject new mechanics and updated mechanics to the lair
bosses across the board to introduce that hiked challenge but in an interesting way that's just
more fun i guess really for us to enjoy um we have a question related to uh i'm going to speed through
a few last questions here um lilith will will lilith ever make a entry into maybe the boss layer system
or anything this is from ganon north yeah i think uh that's something that we've been thinking about and
like what's the right place and what's the right time for something like that um she's in an
interesting spot now where she's kind of like the pinnacle of the season's journey a lot of times and
that's something we can definitely think about especially with this revamped flow of being able
to summon the bosses um so we can definitely take that into consideration that'd be a lot of fun
um quick question related to the spirit born this is from the schwab uh does the new russian claw aspect
power give you all the previous bonuses at four plus charges or just the extra cast uh it's just the extra one so it
it's um so if you're casting it at four or more charges it only hits an extra time it does not get
guaranteed crit or overpower uh or heal you it's uh you kind of either progress through one benefit at
a time or you just get the four plus if you're using uh the new upgrade uh i'm gonna do two quick
last questions i will end on the one that everyone's asking i see it in chat don't worry uh the uh in regards to
um i lost it there it is uh from mid central vowel uh at what point will you start maybe potentially
removing uniques that have proven to be not that useful um or do you guys feel like uniques are
feeling bloated in this in the current setup i i think um i actually feel like we don't necessarily
have enough uniques in terms of speaking to every skill like i think that's something that you see with
the poison trap and you see with ice shards um that is sort of why we have the boss ladder to give
you more deterministic or maybe not deterministic but targeted ways to find some of the uniques
you're looking for this lets us have a lot of different uniques but things that you actually have
to target um the other thing i'll just say too is like part of the game is random items and figuring
out how to assemble a build out of the random items so like we don't want to get to a place where
i just sort of log into diablo and i get all the uniques i want and then i'm sort of done with the
game and it's just sort of this linear deterministic track through getting the pieces that that you
want um but that said like we're always sort of listening to the feedback and if it does start to
feel like where i'm just constantly sifting through things i don't care about those are things that we
can absolutely take a look at yeah and i think on the design side when we're looking at unique designs
i think uh there are still some spots in the game like with poison trap this season where there were
some skills or some play styles that had um you know had some threads there but it wasn't really a
complete and cohesive build and still require a bit more support so we're still going to be looking
for those opportunities to to support um builds or play styles that we think are interesting and fun
with new uniques every season um but additionally we are also taking a look at at kind of that the
you know the catalog of uniques we have in the game so a good example on rogue again is that the
scoundrel's leather this season uh that was an item that was uh sometimes played but not often for
its actual unique effect for some of its affixes actually it was pretty powerful um but its unique effect was was
pretty lackluster and so we've done a just a whole rework on it we said hey what's the identity of
this well it's it's talking to to death trap builds in a way but in a way that wasn't super compelling
and so we said well let's let's kind of scrap that existing effect and and how can we better support
that let's take another try at this um so that's one way that we're going to look at uh to to find those
underused uniques that really maybe don't find a home uh we're going to constantly be reevaluating them
and seeing how we can kind of plus them up and and make them achieve the potential and fulfill that that
build a niche that that they were intended to do in the first place all right i mean i ended with the
last question because if everyone's asking this related to aspirational content is there going to
be are there more plans for that things like whether it's a potential leaderboards to more like end game
type of features and stuff do we where are we in regards to some of that yeah i'll say the team
absolutely this is top of mind and something that we absolutely want to improve in terms of adding
more milestones for you to reach uh more satisfying and more rewarding milestones and celebrating those
milestones so the team is actively sort of looking at what are ways that we can level up some of the
aspirational feel of the game i'll also say just in season eight again a lot of the torment tiers and
bosses have really been leveled up and i'll say again the pit has been pretty massively buffed so
there are uh some tuning changes we've made just to make the game the pieces that we have today
a little bit more aspirational and challenging and satisfying to overcome we really think season
seven was a fun candy rush and it was a it was a sugar rush uh sort of like the smoothie smoothies
everyone's uh been shrinking behind not everyone uh not everyone yeah only the important
people behind the screen that it got delivered midstream
yeah marcus redeemed yeah but uh like uh season seven was really fast and we do think when the
game reaches that state if we're just nothing really you have to work for it and it's just really fast
and it's over in a weekend totally there's not enough things to work towards so we are sort of taking
an approach again with some of the balance changes to make some of the game feel a little bit more
aspirational and it's a focus for our team going forward yeah and i i will say we've had conversations
about this i feel like almost weekly colin and i talk about it a whole lot i know uh there's a
there's a lot of discussions happening and a lot of uh people uh thinking about that that specifically
from that end so um a huge shout out and thanks to you guys for for jumping in uh and to ruben of
course for for jumping into the build and and running through everything um again ptr is going to be
starting next tuesday you can early download on pc battle net starting monday afternoon california time
um and we will have a blog and patch notes and everything available for people to check out
immediately after this stream uh really looking for to everyone jumping in testing out uh the the new
boss layer system of course uh the new powers that are associated with it all the class changes and all
the quality of life stuff that we talked about with in terms of like the leveling journey as you're going
up uh within this new season so uh really looking forward to everyone jumping in uh please make sure to
uh take advantage of giving us your feedback on the forums or reddit or discord other places uh we're
going to be most definitely checking out uh starting all next week um so thank you guys again we have
march of the goblins which are which is uh currently going on in diablo 4 and we have a d2r ladder reset
tonight so if you're a big d2r person like feel free to jump in it's always a fun time uh we will see
you guys in the ptr next week and really appreciate it thanks all thanks everyone